basketball
since I was a kid I fell in love with
this game
[Applause]
and when I'm gliding through the air
it's like pressing mute on everything
else
this car said has arrived news
get your butt to school
[Music]
giving all of your options you have to
decide you want to be good at the next
level or do you want to be great
[Music]
a cedar coat Pro I expect you to be
acutely mindful and acutely prepared not
just on the hardwood Mr Carson
understood understood
Chase has got too much riding on his
senior year we need to know he's with
someone who will watch his back who did
say if I haven't needed anything
[Applause]
horrible stop because my best friend
stepped up and did something about it
unfortunately I don't think it would be
likely that things will work out for him
all the work you've done you're so close
when you put it all at risk I had to you
could go to jail
who else was with you that night let's
go let's go he attacked a man with the
help of three others everyone is
watching now is the time to stand with
the kids our school's reputation is at
stake
I feel like I'm drowning don't let other
people's opinion become my reality oh
[Music]
it ain't ready for what's about to
happen
close
I'm on
[Music]